I want to continue in Volume 2 with March 14, 1899, the evil of man forces God to chastise
him. This morning my sweet Jesus transporting me with him, this is in and out of the body
experience for Louisa, made me see the multiplicity of the sins that are committed. They were
such and so many that it is impossible to describe them. I could also see a star of
enormous magnitude in the air, and within its roundness it contained black fire and
blood. Well you do know that in late 20th century that the what they call the planet
X or the 10th planet, also called Nibiru, was discovered and after that then NASA wanted
to pretend it didn't happen because it was causing such fear around the world. This planet
is so very much bigger than planet Earth and its orbit takes about 2600 years and it's
on its way. So the black fire and blood would make enormous sense if this planet is coming
close to us, the damages will do will be colossal. Louisa says it would strike so much fear and
fright even looking at it that it seemed that death would be the lesser evil than to live
in these times so sad. In other places one could see volcanoes with their mouths opening
which are also to inundate the country nearby. So there are a lot of volcanoes in Italy,
that's what she means by the country nearby. One could also see sectarian people, now it's
a strange expression that she uses but since Italy was catholic, sectarian people have to
be the communists and the Freemasons who will also go on causing fires. Now fire doesn't
here doesn't mean just setting a house on fire, it means trouble of all kinds. While
I was seeing this my beloved and afflicted Jesus told me, "Have you seen how much they
offend me and what I keep prepared?" That means the judgment that's waiting for them
if they really push divine justice that far. I am withdrawing from man, now this is the
worst punishment of all. If you go to Ezekiel chapter 10 and 11 you'll see that the Spirit
of God actually lifted up from the temple in chapter 10, hovered over the temple because
it was his home on earth and then left and on that particular occasion the people repented
and so in chapter 11 the Spirit of God comes back and takes up his residence in the temple.
When you read Romans chapter 1 and Saint Paul speaks about the dreadful, dreadful corruption
of the city of Rome in his day, three times he says God left them to their terrible practices,
God left them to their terrible immorality and God left them. Now that means of course
that the Empire of Rome was going to fall and it did. As he was saying this, we both
withdrew into my bed and I could see that because of this withdrawal of Jesus people
would give themselves over to the most awful actions and more murders. That's what happens
you see when grace is withdrawn because God is grace, grace is an outpouring of God and
if grace is removed then people are worse than animals. Once we had withdrawn Jesus
seemed to place himself in my heart and he began to cry and sob saying oh man how much
I have loved you. If you knew how I grieved to have to chastise you. So Jeremiah 31 3
I have loved you with an everlasting love and I am constant in my affection for you.
Even God's justice is love because all of God's attributes are equal and they are all
intermingled as one. For example, justice is merciful because if you get justice on the
earth maybe you might repent and you won't go to hell. Justice is wise because it treats
you properly on the earth so that you don't lose your soul and so on. But we think that
mercy means being let off the hook and that God doesn't call us to account but mercy is
just and mercy is wise and mercy is prudent and all the rest of it and love is just and
love is kind and love is merciful as well. So all the attributes of God intermingle.
If you only knew how I grieve in having to chastise you Jesus said but my justice forces
me to do this oh man oh man how I cry and grieve over your lot and then he burst into
tears again and he would repeat those words because he loves us. John 15 9 as the Father
has loved me so I have loved you. So this love is infinite absolute eternal and so of
course Jesus would grieve over the way we are destroying ourselves as individuals societies
and the world. Who can say the pity the fear the torment that arose in my soul especially
in seeing Jesus so afflicted and crying I did as much as I could to hide my sorrow and
in order to console him I said to him oh Lord it will never be that you will chastise man
holy spouse do not cry justice you have done the other times you will do now you will pour
your justice into me you see that's the incredible mercy that God has given to the human race
that he calls victim souls who will stand between his divine justice and the human race.
You will make me suffer so that your justice will not force you to chastise the rest of
them. Jesus would continue crying and I would repeat but listen to me a little bit have
you not put me in this bed so that I might be a victim soul for others you have to add
the word soul because the word victim gives a different message today have I perhaps not
been ready to suffer the other times so as to spare them why do you not want to listen
to me now and with all my poor words my book says speaking for words is a better rendition
with all my poor words Jesus couldn't come and sell from crying so no longer able to
hold it I too broke the dyke of my crying saying to him Lord if your intention is to
chastise them I too do not have the heart to see them suffer so much therefore if you
truly want to send the scourges and my sins no longer make me worthy to suffer in the
place of others I want to come put their two Corinthians five eight we are full of confidence
and actually want to be exiled from the body and make our home with the Lord I want to be
on this earth no more then the confessor came and called me to obedience and Jesus withdrew
and that's how it ended the following morning I kept seeing Jesus withdrawn within my heart
and I saw that people would come even inside my heart and would tread upon him and trample
him underfoot I would do as much as I could to free him and Jesus turning to me said do
you see where the gratitude of man actually reaches they themselves force me to chastise
them and I cannot do otherwise and you my dear one after you've seen me suffer so much
may you hold crosses more dearly and pains as delights that's Hebrews 12 to to hold pains
as delight does not mean of course that you don't suffer that you don't feel the pain
but that you know the value of it so Hebrews 12 to says that for the joy that was set before
him he endured the cross despising the shame of it so March the 18th 1899 charity is simple
I want to give you one John four seven God is love so charity or divine love is simple
so just make sure you write down divine love there that it's not human love you're talking
about this morning my beloved Jesus continue to make himself seen from within my heart
and in seeing him a little bit more cheered I plucked up courage and I began to pray that
he would not send so many chastisements and Jesus asked me what moves you my daughter
to pray not to chastise the creatures in other words what's your intention now in all of these
writings your intention is extremely important it's not what you do it's why you do it that
is terribly important and therefore all of us have to get to the point of being able
to confess in confession I did such and such a thing for this reason this is why I did
it and if we can confess this is why I did it we are actually getting places because
the priest will know how to help you to repent immediately Louisa answered because they are
your images and if the creatures should suffer you yourself would suffer so the images of
God is Genesis one twenty seven and Romans eight twenty nine and Jesus heaving a sigh said
ah it's divine love is so dear to me one John three two that you cannot understand it divine
love is simple just like my being which though immense is yet most simple you'll read that
also in wisdom chapter seven so much so that there is no place in which it does not penetrate
so I keep on saying divine love so you don't misunderstand the word charity because it's
charity is used bandied around today and it has lost its extraordinary meaning so divine
love being very simple it diffuses everywhere and you'll also read you know that the divine
light is so very simple that it diffuses everywhere but the divine light and the divine
love are one they're the same person it has regard for no one whether a friend or an enemy
whether citizen or a stranger it loves everyone it loves without limits this is love without
borders and what Jesus demanding of us is love without borders as one Corinthians fourteen
one Matthew five thirty four to thirty eight that we must be perfect like our heavenly father
is perfect so March the ninth eighteen ninety nine the devil can speak about virtue but
he cannot infuse it into the soul now this is important for discernment this morning as
Jesus made himself seen I was afraid it might not be truly Jesus but the devil who wanted
to deceive me and after I made my usual protests Jesus began to speak now there's a little
note here saying protest is not intended as an act of disapproval or dissent but as an
interior affirmation of the soul and oath of her intention of consenting to no temptation
to the enemy in volume one Louisa writes Jesus Christ taught me that the most effective means
for the soul to be freed of every vain apprehension of every doubt of every fear was to protest
before heaven earth and the very demons that she does not want to offend God that's extremely
important point and if you want to overcome temptations quickly just make that declaration
she calls it a protest but in actual fact it should be called a declaration and that is
we say before heaven earth and hell I wanted to clear before the father before all the angels
and saints and before all creatures on earth and all demons and hell that I want to love
God only I want to serve him only I want to love him only I will not under any circumstances
consent to sin that's the declaration or the protest that she's actually talking about
so after she made her declaration then Jesus said to her daughter do not fear for I am
not the devil besides he if he speaks about virtue it's a colored thing colored meaning
something you color on a page in other words there's no reality to it it's not real virtue
and nor does he have the power of infusing it into the soul he can only talk about it
we say of people who can only talk about things and never do anything that they're all mout
a lovely expression that I've come across from the pharaohs in Egypt is a wind bag in
other words there's no reality there you can look you can stick a pin in it and the wind
goes out so the devil is a wind bag he's only talking about something that doesn't mean anything
and if sometimes the devil shows that he wants to make the soul practice a little bit of
good she the soul is not persevering because there's no grace involved and in the very
act in which the soul does that little bit of good she's listless and agitated because
there's no grace there it's not coming from God I alone have the power to infuse myself
in her heart that means to infuse grace power wisdom understanding fortitude knowledge and
so on I alone have the power to infuse myself in her heart to make her practice virtues
and to get her to suffer with courage tranquility and perseverance now the devil won't help you
to suffer and certainly not to suffer with perseverance and constancy for God and then
when is the devil ever gone in search of virtues his hunting is for vices that's his
thing and to bring down the human race therefore don't fear and be tranquil so March the 20th
1899 this morning Jesus transported me out of myself and showed me so many people all
in discord they're out of God's order and if you look at the beginning of this volume
and any volume of Louisa you'll see the declaration that this is all about the call of the creature
to return to the order the place and the purpose for which God had created it so disorder means
out of God's will man doing his own thing oh how much this grieved Jesus Louisa said in
seeing him suffer so much I prayed him to pour it into me but since he still continues
in wanting to chastise the world he did not pour it into me however after I prayed and
prayed him to make me content he poured a little bit and then being a little relieved
he told me the reason why the world has reduced itself to such a sad state is that it has
lost subordination to leaders and also the first leader is God now I want you to know
that he's talking about the death of obedience when Satan is around there will be no obedience
and here we are in the third millennium and religious life has disintegrated because there's
no obedience the church is falling apart because there's no obedience everybody does their
own thing society is falling apart you have to do your own thing you have to assert yourself
it's you yourself that you're serving worshiping and all the rest of it and the selfie to me
is the image of self worship today it's frightening so the fact that there's no obedience no acceptance
of God's order and the first leader is God against whom they have rebelled so therefore
they meaning the human beings have rebelled against the Ten Commandments well by now in
the third millennium our governments have made the Ten Commandments obsolete it's actually
legal to be immoral and then he said it happened as a consequence that they have lost any subjection
to or dependence on the church the laws and all the others are said to be leaders because
they've no obedience to God of course obedience to the church is gone as well and therefore
everybody's doing their own thing and the most perfect illustration of that are the demonstrations
we have witnessed in which women have said nobody will tell me what to do with my body
they have no idea the level of rebellion that is actually there and they don't appear to
think that their bodies were given to them everything is gift and my daughter what will
happen to so many members infected by this bad example of the very ones who are said
to be leaders that is superiors parents and many others ah they will reach such a point
that neither parents nor brothers nor kings nor princes will be recognized anymore which
of course has happened these members will be like many vipers that will poison one another
therefore see how necessary chastisement are in these times and how necessary it is for
death to almost destroy this sort of people so that the few who will be left may learn
at the expense of the others to be humble and obedient so let me do do not want to oppose
by chastising the people now if you want to see the chaos that comes into society where
everybody's doing their own will and not God's will and the deterioration that happens in
families and in society read to Timothy 3 verses 1 to 5 it's very sobering also read
Revelation 1118 where the Lord says that he will destroy the destroyers of the earth so
the Lord says that certain poisonous plants have to be removed in order to let the ones
that still have some health live and so the chastisements are actually very selective
the people in areas where disasters have happened wouldn't think that at all march 31st 1899 and
this is the value of suffering this morning my adorable Jesus made himself seen crucified
and after he communicated his pains to me he told me many are the wounds that made me suffer
during my passion but the cross is just one reality this means that many are the roads
through which I draw souls to perfection but one is the heaven in which these souls must
unite now the English very often is very poor because the adverbs and the nouns are put
in the wrong place for the English language so Jesus is saying that even though he had
thousands of sufferings the mystery of the cross is one reality and he says even though
heaven is the destiny for all human beings there are many roads together and even people
who are together in one class they may be on different roads to heaven as well because
that's like saying you can travel to Dublin but you may not travel on the motorways you
might travel the country roads you might decide to go through the small towns on your way
there are different ways of getting there and even entering the city you can enter it
from different angles and so on well that's the way it is spiritually that we take different
roads to heaven so this heaven that we are aiming at has different places in it more
or less glorious so I want to give you John 14 too for that in my father's house there
are many mentions and there is one for you and these places will be distributed according
to the sufferings suffered down here on earth more or less heavy oh if all knew the preciousness
of suffering they would compete with one another to suffer more but this knowledge the word
in my book says science this knowledge is not recognized by the world and so they abhor
all that can make them richer for eternity so there are many roads to heaven but you won't
get there without the cross these writings are completely clear that you cannot get there
without the cross if you reject the cross you've rejected the journey and people accept the
cross at different levels some people just put up with it some people rebel against it
some people resign themselves some people actually agree and they allow the cross to
do its purifying work inside of us and Jesus says the more deeply the cross is allowed to
do that purifying work in us the greater will be your place in heaven because all the purification
is supposed to happen on the earth it's not supposed to happen in purgatory and purgatory
is just a very severe mercy on the part of God for those who went to the other side not
fully prepared so Louisa continues after going through several days of privation and tears
I found myself all confused and annihilated within myself in my interior I kept saying
continuously tell me oh my god why have you moved away from me where have I offended you
that you no longer make yourself seen and if you show yourself you are almost concealed
and silent oh please do not make me wait and wait any longer for my heart cannot take anymore
now this is only volume two we're at the very beginning and there's 36 volumes altogether
so Louisa at this point doesn't understand what she calls the privation and it will be
called the privation for the whole of these volumes and that that is that Jesus is not
showing himself to her in this extraordinary way that he showed before and so she suffers
desperately but she's going to learn as she goes along that her biggest cross never mind
all the sufferings she agrees to and all the rest of it but her biggest cross is actually
this privation and Jesus will explain to her in higher volumes that she does in fact experience
the pain of purgatory and sometimes even the pain of hell the pain both pains are the pain
of the loss of God and she will learn eventually how to use it for the good of souls finally
Jesus showed himself a little more clearly and in seeing we so annihilated devastated
we would say he told me if you knew how much I like humility will go to Matthew chapter
11 verses 28 to 30 humility is the littlest plant that can be found but its branches are
so high that they reach heaven they wind their way around my throne and they penetrate deep
into my heart this little plant is humility and the branches which this plant produces
are confidence so there cannot be true humility without confidence humility without confidence
is false virtue from the words of Jesus it shows that my heart not only annihilated it
was also a little discouraged and so you need to write down the two words humility and confidence
because you're going to hear an awful lot more about them in fact as you go to the higher
volumes it's not just humility that Jesus will ask for but he will ask us to acknowledge
our nothingness that by comparison with him we are literally nothing and that he creates
out of nothing and so if we would throw ourselves into our nothingness then he will be able
to create a wonderful new thing in us and through us and so he is introducing the subject
here in the early volumes because volumes one to four are the foundations of this great
mysterious journey that brings so much glory to God so April the 5th 1899 how Jesus keeps
her concealed in his love my soul continues in its annihilation and fear of losing sweet
Jesus when in one instant he made himself seen all of a sudden and he told me I keep
you in the shadow of love now the word is charity on the page it's divine love we're talking
about since a shadow penetrates everywhere my love keeps you concealed everywhere and
in everything now that confirms that I'm talking about divine love because only divine love
is everywhere and in everything so if Louisa is held in the arms of divine love divine
love is everywhere and in everything what do you fear then how can I leave you when
I keep you so sunken within my love and of course God is love so it means that she's
absolutely absorbed in God while Jesus was saying this I wanted to ask him why he was
not making himself seen as usual but Jesus disappeared from me immediately and did not
give me the time to tell him even a word you can see from this response of Louisa that
she hasn't grasped that Jesus has answered her question she wants to know why she's not
seeing him all the time and he says but you are literally absorbed in me that's like you
pour a drop of water into a bucket of water you're not going to be able to see the drop
of water anymore because it's completely absorbed by the rest of it and he's telling her something
incredible here but she can't hear it and that's because she's suffering April the seventh
1899 Louisa refreshes Jesus so she says I continuing in the same state but this morning
especially it seemed most bitter to me I'd almost lost the hope that Jesus would come
again so you need to put beside that Sam 63 which laments the Lord's absence oh God you
are my God for you I love for you my soul is thirsty even my body pines for you like
a dry weary land without water so she says how many tears I have shed that Sam 42 as well
I have nothing but tears for my bread night and day as I hear it said all day long where
is your God oh God what am I going to do my heart was in such strong pain and continuous
throbbing but so strong that I felt mortal agony in my interior I said to him my good
Jesus don't you yourself see that I feel life missing in me now Louisa's not actually exaggerating
there because she's in a bed there's nothing happening around her she's not eating as other
people each she's not sleeping as other people sleep she has nothing to do except pray and
commune commune commune with God and write her books which she finds very difficult to do
and so since she's living this abnormal existence that should have brought her muscle wastage
and bed sores and osteoporosis and God knows what else she never had any illness except the
one from which she died which was pneumonia in her 80s the old man's friend as the doctor
say okay so why does she say life is missing in her and that is that Jesus is literally
preserving her body soul and spirit he isn't just preserving her spiritually and so when
he is not more actively present to her she feels that she's actually dying and she's
not exaggerating my good Jesus don't you yourself see that life is missing in me tell me at least
how can one be without you how can one live though I am ungrateful for so many graces
yet I love you and I offer you this most bitter pain of your absence to repair for my ingratitude
now that's the right thing to do is to offer the pain for something but come she says have
patience Jesus you are so good don't make me wait anymore come and don't you yourself
know what a cruel tyrant love is and you don't have compassion on me so what she's saying
there is that true love genuine love demands union with the beloved demands unity true love
won't tolerate separation so while I was in this state so sorrowful Jesus came and all
full of compassion he told me I've come now do not cry anymore come to me in one instant
I found myself outside of myself together with him so she's in and out of the body experience
and I looked at him but with such fear that I might lose him again that tears would pour
in large streams from my eyes and Jesus continued no don't cry anymore take a look at how I
am suffering look at my head the thorns that are penetrated so deep that they no longer
show outside do you see how many gases and blood cover my body come close to me and give
me refreshment so what he is doing he is deflecting her from looking at her own sufferings to
look at his because if she looks at his sufferings she knows what to do and that is that she
will take some of these sufferings to herself to give him what he calls a refreshment please
don't misunderstand for you and me a refreshment is a cup of tea or a coffee or a drink or
something it's not so for him a refreshment means that she will take some of his sufferings
to relieve him and therefore to save souls and he will also mitigate chastisements for
her as well so by occupying myself with the pains of Jesus Louisa said I forgot about my
own which was the issue a little bit and so I started from his head oh how harrowing it
was to see those thorns so sunk into his flesh that one could not pull them out while I was
doing that Jesus would lament so great was the pain that he suffered after I pulled the
crown of thorns off all broken I put it together again and knowing that the greatest pleasure
one can give Jesus is to suffer for him that's because it will save souls not because suffering
in its own self I took it and I drove it into my own head so Louisa was suffering moral
and spiritual suffering and she takes physical suffering on top of that as well then he would
he would had me kiss his wounds one by one and in some of them he would want me to suck
all the blood you will see this in the hours of the passion where you see Jesus doing this
on a spiritual level kissing all the wounds of Jesus in order to make reparation and to
save souls I was trying to do everything he wanted though in mute silence when the most
holy virgin came and said to me ask Jesus what he wants to make of you in other words
there is a program there is an adventure there is a calling there is a vocation and
Louisa is thinking that she has experienced what needs to be experienced and not at all
it does an incredible journey ahead for her so blessed mother asks her to ask him I would
not dare she said but mother encouraged me to do it to make her content I drew my lips
near to the ear of Jesus in a whisper I said to him what do you want to make of me and
he answered I want to make of you the object of my satisfactions and in the very act of
saying these words he disappeared and I found myself inside of myself so she gets an answer
which isn't an answer but indicates to her that there is much more much more to come
she hasn't seen anything yet Louisa has no idea at this particular point that she's being
called into the divine will at such a depth that she herself will be encouraged and graced
to open the kingdom of the divine will for the rest of us she wouldn't have understood
those words at this particular point so April the 9th 1899 Jesus refreshes her from the
pains of his privation this morning Jesus made himself seen and transported me into
a church in other words by located her into a church there I attended holy mass and I
received communion at the hands of Jesus after this I clung to his feet but so strongly
that I could not attach myself the thought of the pains of the past days that is of the
privation of Jesus made me fear so much that I might lose him again that while at his feet
I cried and I said this time Jesus I will not leave you anymore because when you go away
from me you make me suffer so much so I want to give you a song of songs chapter three
verses one to four and I also want to give you John 20 verses one to ten where Mary of
Magdalene did exactly the same thing on Easter day she threw herself at the feet of Jesus
and clung to him and she didn't want to let him go but in both cases Jesus went because
we can't cling to him like that Jesus told me come into my arms for I want to refresh
you from the pains of the past days so in the last message she refreshed Jesus from his
pains now he refreshes her also I almost did not dare to do it but Jesus stretched out
his hands and raised me from his feet he hugged me and he said do not fear but I won't leave
you that's Joshua one five Hebrews 13 five this morning I want to make you content come
and stay with me in the tabernacle I want to give you John 14 18 and so we both withdrew
into the tabernacle that that of course is Louisa's soul not our body who can say what
we did he would kiss me and I him and then I would rest in him and Jesus in me and I
would see the offenses that he received in the most holy Eucharist understood and because
they're in the tabernacle and would make acts of reparation for the different offenses who
can express the patience of Jesus in this most holy sacrament it is so great that is
frightening just to think about it but while I was doing this Jesus made me see the confessor
who was coming to call me into myself he told me enough now go over obedience is calling
you seemed that my soul would return to my body and indeed the confessor was calling
me to obedience so April the 12th 1899 Jesus says being in the most blessed sacrament for
me is the same as being in your heart this is terribly important today without having
me wait so long Jesus came quickly and he told me you are my tabernacle that is one
Corinthians 3 16 no you not that you are the temple of the living God and that God dwells
in you being in the most holy Eucharist for me is the same as being in your heart or rather
in you I find something more I'm able to share my pains with you and to have you with
me a living victim soul before the divine justice which of course I don't find in the
tabernacle and while saying these words he enclosed himself within me so the tabernacle
is a dead thing there's no response and the heart is the living tabernacle and he only
tolerates the dead tabernacle in order to come into our hearts and reign there the living
tabernacles so while within me Jesus would make me feel the pricks of the thorns and
the pains of the cross and the labors and the sufferings of his heart around his heart
I could see a braid of iron spikes which made Jesus suffer very much how much pity I felt
in seeing him suffer this way I would have wanted to suffer everything myself rather
than let my sweet Jesus suffer and from the heart I prayed to him to give his pains and
sufferings to me then he told me daughter the offenses which most pierced my heart are
the masses that are said sacrilegiously and the hypocrisy of the priests who can say what
I understood about these two words it seemed to me that externally one shows that he loves
and praises the Lord but internally he has poison ready to kill him externally one shows
that he wants the glory and honor of God but internally he sees his own honor and esteem
all works done with hypocrisy even the holiest ones are works completely poisoned which embittered
the heart of Jesus so first of all I want to give you Matthew 23 where Jesus absolutely
castigated the scribes and Pharisees for their hypocrisy they had the holy robes they had
the holy jobs that our cardinals bishops and priests have today they were carrying out
the holy liturgies as our cardinals bishops and priests are today and yet they were the
very ones that Jesus condemned absolutely while when ordinary sinners came to him he was compassionate
with them because they were only weak and therefore they were prepared to open their
hearts to him and to come to him and receive the grace of conversion some of the wonderful
conversions in the gospel like Zacchaeus like Mary of Magdalene for example they seemed to
have been absolutely terrible but they were like the prodigal son in the parable of the
prodigal son that while they were doing awful things their hearts were not actually closed
against God whereas the people who are in the position of cardinals bishops and priests
today who have all the right jobs all the right clothes all the right privileges and
absolutely everything else they might be the ones like the elder brother in the parable of
the prodigal son whose hearts are wrong that's very very very sad it's very sad so look at one
Corinthians 10 and one Corinthians a level where Jesus speaks about sins that are committed during
the Eucharist so April the 16th 1899 this is a preparation for communion and again Jesus speaks
about sins given to him by his own now his own are the people who are committed to him these are
the cardinals bishops and priests and the religious and obviously whatever laity are really committed
to him while I was in my usual state Louisa said Jesus invited me to go around and see
what the human creatures were up to I said to him my adorable Jesus this morning I don't feel like
going around and seeing the offenses that they give you let's stay here just the two of us together
now of course that's the temptation we all have let's stay here just nice and causative and we
don't have to look at it but in actual fact you do have to see what's going on so that you'll make
reparation but Jesus insisted that he wanted to go around and so to make him content in other
words to please him I said to him if you want to go out let me rather go inside some churches in
other words she thought it wouldn't be so bad to go inside churches rather than the so-called
big bad world because the offenses that they give you are fewer there so we went inside a church
but there also he was offended more than in other places and this is the shock
not because more sins are committed in the churches than in the world
but because these are offenses given to him by his dearest ones his closest ones but everybody
knows this in their ordinary everyday life the people living on the next street to you are not
the ones who cause you the gracious pain they are the people in your own household the ones that you
call spous and children and relatives and all the rest they have the the ability to cause you
more pain than anybody else so these are the offenses given by his dearest ones by the very ones who
should lay down their soul and body to defend the honor and glory of god this is why they reach his
adorable heart more painfully I could see devout souls now devout souls to her seems to be we would
think lay people but they seem to be religious and priests but let's include the laity as well
who because of baguetels of no importance you know Shakespeare wrote a play called what you do about
nothing and this is the me me me stuff and you're getting all head up about absolute nothings
and she calls them baguetels of no importance and they did not prepare well for communion
oh dear instead of thinking of Jesus their minds were thinking about their little disturbances
about the many trifles and this was their occupation oh dear I hope and I presume that you you are not
among these people most of the rest of us are how Jesus pity to them and how much pity they themselves
aroused they paid attention to so many straws and so many specs but then they didn't as much as
give a glance to Jesus they can even walk up to communion completely distracted and they can be
completely distracted afterwards and then you have the scandal that people walk out after mass
and the first thing they're doing is gossiping outside do they even know they have received Jesus
so I want to give you Matthew chapters one to six or Matthew six one to six I think that should be
Matthew six one to six Jesus said to me my daughter how these souls prevent my grace from pouring
into them now I can't think of anything more tragic than you're going to mass every single day
and at the same time preventing grace from transforming us I can't think of anything worse
I do not look at trifles but I look at the love with which they come to me
yet they make an exchange they pay more attention to straws than to love but love is the issue
and in the 36 volumes of Louisa I can summarize it for you no problem divine will and love if you
go to Matthew 22 Jesus describes that love is the most important of all of the laws and he says the
whole of the scripture hangs on love and love is the issue with God because God is love okay
so it's one John four seven God is love love is the issue when we go in death into God's kingdom
the only baggage you can take with you is love and everything that love contains all the other
trifles have to be left on the earth so many good people who appear very good to us may in fact go
to God without any baggage and therefore they have to go to purgatory unfortunately I do not look
at trifles he says I look at the love with which they come to me yet they make an exchange they pay
more attention to straws than to love but while love destroys the straws if only we received communion
reverently the Lord would deal with all of these nothings in our lives with many straws love cannot
increase even a little bit oh dear rather it decreased so if we give all our attention to the straws
we don't give grace the opportunity to do anything to us if we put the straws aside and go and receive
Jesus with great love love will actually deal with the straws so they waste much time they would
like to spend entire hours with their confessors and talk to them about trifles but they never get
down to the work to work with a good and courageous resolution in order to root the straws out now
louis is talking about something that was very common at the time that she is speaking about
which is over a century ago and that is that people thought it was very holy to spend hours in a
confessional talking to the priest about all kinds of total nonsense and straws as you're told here
but my new details and in the first four volumes of louis's writings Jesus will tell us all to get
rooted that junk because all you're doing is paying an awful lot of attention to yourself
and paying no attention to love and as long as all this attention is given to yourself then
there's no way you can grow so they they want to spend hours talking to the priest about these
trifles but they never get down to work with a good and courageous resolution to get these straws
out of their lives so it's an awful lot better to conquer yourself than keep talking about the
stuff what should i tell you then oh my daughter about certain priests of these times one can say
that they operate almost satanically reaching the point of making themselves idols of souls in other
words the priests who are allowing people to come and sort of worship them as holy men because they
listen to all of these nonsense oh yes it is by my sons that my heart is pierced the most now louis
isn't the only person to whom jesus confided that he confided that to many of his friends that is
the priest that cause him the most trouble and we who are living in this very very sad age where
priests and bishops and cardinals have scandalized the whole world with their behavior
we can only grieve we can also make reparation i shouldn't say we can only grieve we can make
reparation and we can make substitution to the lord for them in the divine will
hi yes it's by my sons that my heart is pierced the most because if the others offend me more
they offend me as members of my body but my own offend me in my most sensitive and tender parts
deep into my innermost heart okay who can say the torment of jesus in speaking these words he was
crying bitterly i did as much as i could to sympathize with him and repair him and but while i was doing
this jesus and i together withdrew into my bed okay now we're going to unfortunately hear an
awful lot more about the sins of priests april the 21st 1899 jesus is the poorest of the poor
this morning while i was in my usual state luisa said in one instant i found myself within myself
but without being able to move i realized that someone was entering my little room and then he
closed the door again and i felt he was drawing near in my bed in my mind i thought that someone
had entered furtively without anyone of my family seeing him and had penetrated even into my little
room who knows what he will do to me she thought my fear was so great that i felt my blood freeze
in my veins and i trembled all over oh god what do you do i said to myself my family did not see him
i feel all numb and i cannot defend myself nor can i ask for help jesus mary my mother helped me she
cried out st joseph defend me from this danger when i realized that he was getting upon my bed
and he curled up near me my fear was such that i opened my eyes and i said tell me who are you
he answered i am the poorest of the poor i don't have a place to stay i come to you if you want to
keep me with you in your little room see i am poor and i don't even have clothes but you can take
care of everything i looked well at him he was a five or six year old boy without clothes without
shoes but so very beautiful and graceful immediately i answered him for me i would gladly keep you
but what will my father say i'm not a free person who can do whatever she wants i have my parents
who prevent me as for clothing you i can do it with my poor toils i will make any sacrifice
but as for keeping you here that's impossible besides don't you have a father don't you have a mother
don't you have a place to stay and the boy answered bitterly i have nobody oh please don't make me
wander anymore let me stay with you i myself didn't know what to do how to keep him a thought flashed in
my mind who knows whether it is jesus or maybe it's some demon to disturb me so again i said to him
but tell me the truth at least who are you and he repeated i am the poorest of the poor i replied
have you learned how to make the sign of the cross he said yes well then make it i want to see how you
make it so he signed himself with the cross and i added and the hail mary do you know how to say it
yes but if you want me to say it he said let us say it together i began the hail mary and he was
saying it together with me when a most pure light was unleashed from his adorable forehead and i
recognized that the poorest of the poor was jesus why is he the poorest of the poor because he made
this planet he made it into a paradise and he made all the creatures on it and he has nowhere to stay
he has no heart to live in and nobody will clothe him with love and anything and so that's why he
showed himself to louise as unclothed because his clothing is love because god is love in one instant
through that light jesus sent me he made me lose consciousness again that is going to ecstasy
and drew me outside of myself into and out of the body experience i saw myself all confused
before jesus especially because of my many rebuffs and immediately i said to him my dear little one
forgive me had i recognized you i would not have forbidden you to enter and then why did you not
tell me who's really you i have many things to tell you i would have told them to you and would not
have wasted so many time on useless things and fears besides in order to keep you i don't need
my family i can keep you freely because you don't allow yourself to be seen by anyone but while i was
saying this he disappeared and so it ended leaving me a pain for not having told him anything that i
wanted to tell him now notice that she is so determined to tell him what is in her heart that
she's not paying attention to really what he's trying to reveal to her and the mercy is that the
lord got her to write everything down so that we can learn that we have to pay attention to what the
lord is trying to communicate to us and that we have to put it into practice now of course she will
grow and she will be transformed so i want to finish this segment with april the 23rd 1899
the praises and scorns of others there are two great impostors in life and they are called praise
and blame even people who are not christians and the pagan philosophers were able to say this
because people can praise you for 101 reasons and they can blame you for 101 reasons and none of the
reasons for the praise or the blame may actually be correct so if you're going to be wise you put
both praise and blame aside and if you're working for the lord you only praise him and you don't blame
him of course and you attribute everything you do to him so she says today i made my meditation on
the harm that can come to our souls from the praises that other people give us while i was doing
the application to myself to see whether there was complacency for human praises within me
that's john 544 where jesus said you look for the approval of man but not the approval of god
jesus came close to me and he said when a heart is full of the knowledge of self the praises of
men are like the waves of the sea that rise and overflow but never out of their boundary so
the protection that we have is self knowledge if you know yourself thoroughly then if somebody
tells you something about yourself you know whether they're just it's eyewash you know or
somebody just robbing you up in the same way human praises yell and shout they clamor
they get close even to the heart but in finding it full and well surrounded by strong walls of
knowledge of self unable to find a place for themselves they draw back causing no damage to
the soul the damage is when you accept the praise and you start puffing yourself up and what happens
is secret pride begins to grow now the worst of all diseases that you can get is actually secret
pride because you can't see it it's an extraordinary mercy from god to get you to see pride and once
the the secret pride gets in there then satan has a hook into your being so this is what you must
be careful about taking the praises or the blame and the scorns of others into no account whether
they praise or blame you just leave it all aside and only deal with the lord so i want to leave it
there for this segment